The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, a
recap of last lecture.
We started to talk
about liquids.
I said I couldn't deal
with the liquid using
the approach that we have been
using for dilute particles--
Boltzmann-based
equation, for example.
And so the discussion on liquid
is incomplete and very short.
We started on bulk liquids.
We said a very useful
definition measure
is the radial distribution
function, which
actually measures the
structure of a liquid itself.
And then we introduced the Van
der Waals equation of states.
Historically, it's
very important.
And, of course, we know
the ideal gas equation,
but Van der Waals
equation of state
actually give you the
liquid and solid states--
uh, no, the vapor and
liquid states and also
give you the transition
between the liquid to vapor.
So vapor [INAUDIBLE],,
at least qualitatively.
And then say in terms of
trading the transport,
the liquid, their
approach in the past,
modifying the
Boltzmann equation.
And this eventually was the,
say, Enskog for example.
[? Consider ?] rather
than Boltzmann equation
as a single-particle
distribution
function, two-particle
distribution function.
That was the Enskog
approach, but as I mentioned,
was not very successful because
it can't really deal even with
a very complete Enskog equation,
which I didn't write down,
you cannot deal with liquid.
You can deal with approximate
[? treating ?] the denser gas,
but it can't be
extended to liquid.
So then we talk about
Einstein's approach.
His proposed objective
was to actually determine
the size of molecules,
small particles.
And he can save the
Brownian motion picture,
although there were experiments.
Brownian did experiments
long before Einstein,
but he didn't seem to realize.
And so a lot of his work
was a [? gedunking, ?]
as he is good at.
And he showed that the relation
between the diffusivity
and viscosity, diffusivity
of particles in the fluids
and the viscosity of the fluids.
And then that's an example
of the fluctuation, which
is diffusion, and dissipation,
which is viscosity.
It's an example of a
fluctuation-dissipation
theorem.
And from the Einstein approach,
there was then an extension
to Langevin equation of motion.
So it's essentially f equals
ma, except in the fourth term,
there are two terms.
One is a random driving force,
and the other is a drag force.
So when you have a
particle in a fluid moving,
we know that [? picture ?]
is the [INAUDIBLE]..
But that's actually
very general.
[? It's ?] [? basically ?]
drag force is proportional
to velocity.
And I commented that even the
longevity equation was not
quite right the way it's written
because it didn't consider
this time, the finite
time response when you
use the [? stock ?] solution.
If you actually write down
the time response of the
[? stocks, ?] you
could see a solution,
you actually get an integral
differential equation.
So you've seen integral
question quite a few times.
We will come back
to continue some
of this discussion
in the last lecture,
but then we turn our attention
to deal with surfaces
and [? say ?]
interface in liquids.
And we started with
potentials and the forces.
So what's the most
[? important? ?]
In fact, I think
somewhere I said
before, if you
understand the energy,
you understand momentum, you
understand the second entropy,
you understand at least,
say, all the mechanical work.
And the f equals,
say, the force itself,
is the gradient
of the potential.
So we started
discussing the force.
Particularly, we focused on
the Coulombic force, the force
interaction due to the charge.
We cannot easily deal with
the covalent force, right,
where you have to really solve
the Schrodinger equation.
But for the force interaction
due to the [? charge, ?]
direct, [INAUDIBLE] charge
interaction Coulombic force,
you can write starting with
the [? point-potential ?]
construct, [? with ?] what if
you have two positive-negative
charge together?
That's a dipole.
And then you have one-point
charge to a dipole.
And you have dipole to dipole.
And you can do dipole
to semi-infinite object.
And finally, we give an
expression for example.
What's the force the Van
der Waals force between--
that's the dipole-based model,
dipole interaction between two
semi and infinite [? plates. ?]
And the potential is inversely
proportional to the separation,
D, between these two surfaces.
And this potential is--
you can say when
you go to smaller D,
it goes to more negative.
So it's attractive
potential and so attractive
force between the two surfaces.
And on the top,
the constant here
is also called Hamaker constant.
And it has-- it's
a physical region.
If you learn, say, if
you do a phase change,
you'll probably say this has
a Hamaker constant before.
And [INAUDIBLE] that's the
Casimir force is dipole-dipole.
This Van der Waals force is
dipole-dipole interaction.
And the extension of that
is the Casimir force.
And the Casimir force
is, as I explained,
it was the idea that the
force between the two object,
1 and 2, and can be think
about that the energy stored
in this space between
1 and 2, the medium--
that's right--
could be a vacuum.
And when I think
about energy stored
and there is a zero-point, we
learned that the quantization
one half h nu.
And then how many modes you
have, electromagnetic modes,
in this space?
And if each mode can turn
energy one half h nu,
you do that summation
of the total energy.
And you find out that
either of the two surface
gets closer to
each other, you're
excluding modes so the
energy is decreasing.
And so you have
attractive force.
So that gave the quantum spin
to the Van der Waals force
interaction picture.
And that was [? a ?]
[? Casamirs. ?] Very simple
paper.
If you are interested,
you can read it.
And then there was the
extension by Lifshitz,
the Landau-Lifshitz book.
But Lifshitz is
solving this problem
from electromagnetic dynamics
point of view, basically
[INAUDIBLE] consider the
force interaction, as I say,
due to the zero
point [? jiggling. ?]
So zero point
[? jiggling ?] means what?
There's no temperature
there, right,
so any object is uncertain.
So the position is not fixed.
So zero point has a fluctuation.
And this fluctuating will
generate electromagnetic wave.
The electromagnetic waves
propagate to this side.
And that will create
an interaction
between the two sides.
So you basically [? solve ?]
Maxwell's equation.
And then the jiggling
is, again, connected
with the so-called
fluctuation-dissipation
theorem, so you can calculate
the force interaction
from electrodynamics
perspective.
And that's a much
more generous theory.
So what you have is 1, 2, 3.
And what you need is the
[? dielectric ?] constant,
epsilon 1, which could be
a function of frequency
and epsilon 2, which could
be a function of frequency,
and epsilon 3, which could
be a function of frequency.
So with that, you can
calculate the force interaction
in any medium.
Sometimes, the two medium
in between are not vacuum;
it could be another material.
And in fact, there is a--
in myself even have--
a little bit confusion here.
This concept, again,
if you do phase change,
you'll probably encounter--
how many of you have
heard of disjoining pressure?
Anybody has heard about that?
OK, yeah.
Disjoining pressure is,
again, another concept
that is encountered in
the phase change process.
For example, if you consider the
evaporation of a liquid film,
so you have a corner, and the
liquid the film will spread.
And, of course, there is
a surface tension part.
But there could be another
part, say a very, very thin film
spreading much larger distance.
And people say that's because
of disjoining pressure.
And the reason for
that is you can think
about this as a medium one.
A vacuum is a medium, remember.
Or say any space for
electromagnetic wave
is a medium.
And that the liquid
film is medium 3.
And whatever there is solid,
there is a medium too.
So I can calculate
the three medium.
What then, say, what's
the interaction?
And it turns out that in
some tests, most of the case
this is attractive.
In some cases there,
the force in between
could also be repulsive.
If it's a repulsive
force, then there actually
will be a stable
layer of liquid that's
sustained on the surface.
If it's evaporation,
if it's a heating,
then if you have a liquid film,
you help your heat transfer.
So there is this
disjointing pressure
that people sometimes use.
I think if anyone is interested
in understanding this,
you should look more
into the literature.
So this is the
picture that we have
in terms of the
attractive force.
Where we're going is talking
about, as I mentioned before,
is I have a suspension, I
have particles in the liquid.
And the [? widest ?] suspension,
I can sometimes make this
stable. [? Why ?] sometimes
I can't make it stable?
And of course, if
it's all attractive,
Van der Waals force, then
I will not have stability,
because the particle
eventually glue
to each other and [? sediment ?]
because of gravity.
So what I [? leave ?]
is a repulsive force.
[INAUDIBLE] [? say ?]
[? common ?] repulsive force,
particularly in ionic
solution, like say, water,
is the electric double layer.
So let's spend a little
bit of time discussing
the electric double layer.
So a lot of solid surfaces,
when you immersing
in a solution, the
[INAUDIBLE] the [? surface, ?]
contains charge.
And you can think
about, for example,
if I have oxygen
[? turbulation ?]
on the surface, if I put in
water, what could be happening?
You think this will be a
hydrophilic or hydrophobic
surface?
Does it like water, or
it doesn't like water?
It will be hydrophilic most
likely, because most likely,
the surface has oxygen.
Oxygen is a negative charge.
And the water has a hydrogen.
And the hydrogen and the oxygen
will bind to each other.
And so a lot of surface actually
have a [INAUDIBLE] surface
charge, either because of the
asymmetry of the bonds because
on the surface, atom is
different from internal.
You don't have the surrounding
atoms to balance it.
Or, it's just because it just
absorbed some ions onto it
to have a [INAUDIBLE] [? so ?]
[? a ?] [INAUDIBLE] charge
on the surface.
So you have on
the solid surface,
typically, let's say here,
I'm drawing just the inside.
I got a net balance of charge
on the surface, negative charge.
And now, if I
emerged in a solution
that has positive
and negative ions,
and then you know
that the positive ions
will go towards the
surface just to balance it.
So what happens is
some of these ions
will be pretty much
glued because the bond is
strong enough.
So the first monolayer will
pretty much be like glued
on to the surface.
And once you are, say,
one monolayer away,
the first interaction
decays rapidly,
and the bonding will not be
strong enough to hold them.
So this other counter ions
will move around the surface.
But say because of
the charge imbalance,
so there will be a [? let ?]
more charge mobile ions
in this region in the liquid.
So what we will create
is in the surface region
like a capacitor.
On the say solid side, you
have one type of charged ions,
and on the liquid side, you
got another type of ions.
This forms electrical
double layer.
And in fact, if you
define more carefully
[? and ?] the immobile layer
of ions is a Stern layer.
It's called a Stern test.
OK.
And then the mobile layer
between this Stern layer
and the outside,
where eventually they
will go-- the charge will go to
a neutrality, the bulk region
of the fluids where it's not
influenced by the surface.
So this layer is
the double layer.
If you do
electrochemical devices,
if you do supercapacitors
for example,
where a supercapacitor is--
capacitance is proportional.
If you think about
capacitors, capacitance
is proportional to area.
And it is inversely
proportional to distance
and the dielectric constant.
So a supercapacitor is one that
you create a large surface area
by making nanoporous materials.
And then you put
in the electrolyte.
Because how you can create
that capacitance layer?
You create the electrolyte
and put it into there.
And you hope that the
[? capacitors ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? capacitance ?] between the
electrolyte and solid and using
that to form your
total capacitance
of a supercapacitor.
And in a supercapacitor,
this layer
is very important, not just
to the electric double layer.
And if you do electrokinetics,
electrokinetics including
electroosmosis, and
where the particle moves
or when you apply
electrical field,
or say the liquid [INAUDIBLE]
in the electrokinetics
is [INAUDIBLE]
So both are because either
the particle is charged,
the solid is charged,
or the other case
is a liquid is charged.
So in those cases, the electric
double layer is very important.
And so first, the density
of the ion on the surface.
So density of ion on surface.
And this one can be related
to the case when you have
zero charge on the surface.
So one case that you don't
have any charge on the surface.
What's the density?
So this is the zero
point charge density.
And then we have--
because I have certain ions
absorbed on the surface,
I have then, say, surface
potential and divide by KBT.
So this is essentially
the Boltzmann statistics,
Boltzmann distribution.
If you recall the Boltzmann
distribution, what
we have is the energy over
KBT, the probability of certain
particles having certain energy.
And this energy is
related to-- energy
is related to electrostatic
potential [? beside ?]
by the charge Q.
Normalize to charge.
And the Q is if I
have atom that has
a certain number of
for example protons, Z.
And then Z times E
gives me the charge.
E is the charge per electron.
So Q is ZE.
That's why I have the ZE times
electrostatic potential, which
is surface potential
divided by KBT.
OK.
And this gives me a way to
actually define the surface
potential as a log.
And you can inverse there.
Now, what I would
like to find is
what's the potential
electrostatic
[? and ?] potential distribution
in the double layer?
So because I have a surface
potential besides the surface,
on the surface.
And then when I move
away from the surface,
there will be a distribution
because the potential
eventually will disappear.
I [? don't ?] want to say
how thick is this layer, is
the double layer.
[? So ?] from the
[INAUDIBLE] distribution.
So the way I do it is I look
into the Poisson question,
which is one of the
four Maxwell equations.
So what we had in
the Maxwell equation
is the displacement
divergence equals
the electric charge per unit
volume, a local charge density.
That's what we had before.
And D will be-- let me write
[? one ?] [? D ?] form.
I don't have to do
too complicated.
So I will write epsilon
or epsilon 0 epsilon r.
[? Epsilon ?] r is relative
dielectric constant.
Epsilon 0 is dielectric
constant vacuum.
Together gives me
[? epsilon. ?] And so this
will be times the electric
field because D equals Epsilon
times E, electrical field.
And so electrical field, you
should write a larger epsilon.
I'm running out of symbols.
And dx equals rho.
And electrical field
is the gradient
of the electrostatic
potential, negative gradient.
So I have really
epsilon, epsilon r,
the negative gradient of
electrostatic potential, dx,
squared.
So that's on the left hand
side of the Poisson equation.
On the right hand side, I
need to write my charge.
So recall here is my solid.
And locally, I have
electrostatic potential.
And [? given ?]
electrostatic potential,
I know the energy is a [? Q. ?]
Say, in fact, this is reversed.
Sorry.
This is psi equals to
the energy times Q.
So local energy, electrostatic
energy is Q times psi.
And then, [? no ?] [? core ?]
Boltzmann statistical
distribution for that
[INAUDIBLE] can be written
as, let's say, is I have
a [? Zi-- ?] different
[? species ?] in the solution--
ZiE.
So this is a first
[INAUDIBLE] i.
And per ion, and the
density of the ion,
0 means semi-infinite
[? way. ?] And now,
because locally I have
a potential difference
from the semi-infinite,
so I have ZiE psi.
That's the energy
divided by KBT.
So this is the
Boltzmann distribution.
Boltzmann [? distribution-- ?]
how many particles,
each particle carries
this much charge.
And I sum up with all the
[INAUDIBLE] in the ion.
And here, I got the so-called
Poisson-Boltzmann equation.
Here, we have Poisson.
I don't want to write poison.
How to write Poisson?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Two s?
P-O--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
Boltzmann.
So solving this
Poisson-Boltzmann equation,
you should be able to
obtain the local field,
electrostatic field distribution
in the double layer.
And it turns out this
is not so easy to solve.
In fact, you could solve
this problem more rigorously.
And the first one was
approximate solution.
And this first approximation
was [? by ?] Debye.
It's called the Debye-Huckel
solution theory.
OK.
Debye-Huckel theory.
And it's [? linearized. ?]
So rather
than using the
exponential, we will
assume the exponential
can be [? linearized. ?]
And this happens when
the exponent is small.
So when the potential
is not large,
ZiE psi is much less than KBT.
Remember, KBT is of the order--
KBT is 26 millielectron
volts at room temperature.
So this, in fact, is
a poor approximation.
And in most cases,
the surface potential
will be larger in
many cases that I
know is larger than this value.
So it's not a very good one,
but it's very instructive.
Because of this, I can
actually linearize it.
So epsilon r, epsilon
psi, the x square,
and that equals the I. So
ZiE [INAUDIBLE] linearlize.
So I get 1 minus ZiE
[? psi ?] and then KBT.
And [? infinite ?] [? away ?]
from the double layer,
I have a balance of negative
and positive charge.
So that's neutrality.
So I have positive, negative.
The first term is actually zero.
So what I have then on the
left-hand side if the first
term is 0, I can [? pull ?]
[? out the ?] psi.
I iZi squared e squared and
the KBT [? and the ?] [? end ?]
[? zero ?] i.
So now, I actually get a simple,
second-order differentiable
equation for the potential
distribution near the surface
here.
It's exponential decay function.
As you can see, the second
order, this is your constant.
If I divide the epsilon 0
epsilon r from this side,
this is a constant for
the exponential decay.
So what I have,
then, the potential.
And what I really want to say--
this potential, I should use.
Because I'm dealing
with the double layer,
I should not actually use psi s.
I should use the
potential at this point.
Let's say S0.
That's where I start looking
to the decay, the diffuse layer
here.
So what I have here is psi S0
exponential minus x over delta.
And this delta, the
inverse of this delta
is just the square root
of what I've written here.
So the square root
of i Z i squared eie
squared, and the n 0 i,
epsilon 0, epsilon r, KBT.
So this delta itself, delta
is called the Debye length.
And you go to look at the
literature in semiconductor p-n
junction, the space charge
region is the same expression.
In fact, when you solve for
the potential of p-n junction,
you saw the same
Poisson-Boltzmann equation
and you use this linearization,
you get a similar expression.
And that is also called the
Debye length in p-n junction.
And the history is the
electrochemical battery
cells was long developed
[? between ?] the p-n junction.
So you can say the solid
state devices actually use
this concept that was developed
for the electrochemical
in electrochemistry.
OK.
So it will be interesting
to see what does this mean.
How thick is this Debye length?
If I have water, I
put some salt into it,
what's my Debye length?
I should be able to estimate
given the expression here.
Let's take one example.
I'm going to put one grain
of salt, sodium chloride,
into water.
And put it in one
liter of water.
One cubic meter,
one liter of water.
And what I need to find out--
what's the solution infinite
way?
What's the equilibrium
concentration of the ions?
You see, concentration of
the ions and just dielectric
constant, inverse say
dielectric constant.
And this is an inverse.
So one cubic liter,
say, millimeter.
And the density of salt is 2.5.
So the density is 2.5
grams per cubic centimeter.
So with this, I will get what I
have here is 10 to the minus 3.
So here is 10 to minus
3 cubic centimeter
times 2.5 grams per centimeter.
And I have here
what I have here.
This is a centimeters--
no.
This is centimeter.
And I have 2.5 milligrams
of salt. And then
how much is that
in terms of more?
So I realize my notes has
10 to the minus 3-- order
of magnitude difference.
I forgot this.
So, say in terms of more is
2.5 10 to the minus 3 gram.
And the molar mass of sodium
chloride-- sodium is 11,
chloride is 17.
So the total is 28 times
a multiple factor of 2.
That's my molar mass.
So here, I have
56 grams per mole.
And this will give me 0.045
10 to the minus 3 mole.
So this is my mole number.
And then I also know one more--
I have Avogadro's constant.
So I have how many ions inside?
So what I have here, I multiply
Avogadro's constant Na,
which is 6 10 to the
positive 23 ions per mole.
So I have this
Lambert of ions, 23.
So I will get this equals the--
OK, so the Lambert
density is per liter.
So 0.045 10 to the minus
3 times 6 10 to the 23.
That's the number of ions per
liter is 10 to the minus 3
cubic meter.
And so this cancels.
And what I have is 0.27 10
to the 23 per cubic meter.
That's the [INAUDIBLE]
So if you go to do this,
I think [INAUDIBLE] length here.
Because this one,
what I have, delta,
because the dielectric
constant water is about 80.
Water is very large
dielectric constant.
If you go to a polar liquid,
then the dielectric constant
will be much smaller.
And because of that,
it's actually much harder
to put an ion into
a polar liquid.
So if it's water, you can
dissolve ion much easier
because the large
dielectric constant.
But anyway, so if you
do that, what I have
here originally is 1.5.
But here, because I
realized I missed this,
so it should be 10 to
the third nanometer.
You can go to check.
So this will give me
15 to 20 nanometer,
[INAUDIBLE] nanometer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For Z, do you use
the full nuclear charge,
or the [INAUDIBLE]
nuclear charge?
PROFESSOR: I used the--
no, I use just the valence here.
I should have used the
[? screen. ?] I used
[? screen. ?] Wait a second.
So what should I use?
Z. If I think about it, Z--
Yeah.
You should use [INAUDIBLE]
because it's a [INAUDIBLE]
[? charge ?]
[? you ?] [? have. ?]
Most of [? the ?]
[? electrons ?] is [? glued ?]
on to the [? nucleus. ?]
I should use the charge
of [? the ?] [? charge ?]
of the mobile ions.
So the point is you can
say the typical [? Debye ?]
[? length ?] is of the order--
depends on how much salt you put
there [? of ?] [? order of ?]
[? tens ?] [? nanometers. ?]
You put more salt, your
Debye length will be smaller.
When you put less salt, your
Debye length will be longer.
So this is the influence of the
electric double layer, how far
away they stand in the liquid.
And now, once I have that,
then the next question
is-- this is around
the single surface
and what's the
pressure, and what's
the force between two surfaces.
So to understand that,
I can think about first,
if I have a double layer--
with this, you can also use
this as an effective thickness
of [? for a ?] capacitor.
The capacitor is a positive
or negative charge.
And that's your
effective thickness.
And the good thing is that
with capacitor, the difference
between electric double
layer and [INAUDIBLE]
is that there
really is no charge.
Ions cannot get into the solid.
P-n junction you have
electrons, you have holes,
they can [? recombine. ?]
So you seldom
use a p-n junction
simple p-n junction
junction to store
charge, but you
can use the electrical
double layer to store charge
for the supercapacitors.
And once the ions
get into the solid,
it becomes a chemical reaction.
That's your battery there.
Your battery actually is the
ion gets into the electrode.
So what we have here--
let's look at the pressure.
So I have, for example, I have
negative ion on the surface.
I have counter and positive.
And they will
attract each other.
So I have attractive force.
And if I have force, unless
I have counter force,
otherwise all this ions
should go to the [? plane. ?]
They will move.
So I've got to have
a counter force.
The counter force
is the pressure
I have generated in
the double layer.
So I have a pressure.
I can think of this as a p.
There's a px plus dx.
And this is a dx.
So the balance of
this pressure force
is against the
electrostatic force.
So I write the force balance.
And the force balance will
tell me this is a dp dx.
And negative and [? plus, ?]
[? the ?] density of the charge
comes to the electric field
[? on ?] the charge is d psi
dx.
And this should balance it.
So this is the force balance.
And of course, now I have
the solution for the--
in fact, you can use the
original [? integral ?]
Poisson-Boltzmann equation.
You can write this
as dp equals minus d
psi because you can integrate
the x directly, get rid of it.
And the charge density is the i
ZiE n 0 i exponential minus ZiE
psi and KBT.
So in this case, this is
just the charge density
[? I'm ?] reading in
the right-hand side
of Poisson-Boltzmann equation.
I can integrate without any
approximation in this case.
And if you do integration, I got
a [? P ?] [INAUDIBLE] x minus P
[? at the ?] infinite.
I integrate [? the ?] infinite,
[? the ?] infinite [? way. ?]
This is the concentration is
[? N0i. ?] So I will have sigma
i and the KBT and
[? i ?] x minus N 0 i.
So if you look at this,
and you can think of this
as this is negative
here, so I have
positive ions here trapped.
And I have more positive ions
[? in ?] the infinite way.
So this term is a positive.
So what it means is the
pressure [? of ?] the positive
is higher in the double
layer than the pressure
away from the double layer.
And now, when I
have two surfaces
because I want to look at--
I have direct force interaction.
That's Van der Waals force,
so a Casimir force interaction
between the two surfaces.
That's what we discussed before.
And now, because of the
pressure in the double layer
is a positive, so when I bring
the two surfaces very close,
the pressure is a
positive inside.
They will repulse,
the two surfaces.
So I have a repulsion force that
could balance the attraction
force.
So this is the
repulsive force due
to the electrical double layer.
Now, with that, I can
now start thinking
about when I put [? liquid ?]
particles into liquid when they
are stable because I have
attractive Van der Waals force,
and I have also
repulsive electrostatic,
the double layer force here.
So in terms of the
separation of the two
particles in the
liquid, when they
are getting closer
[? to ?] closer,
that's the Van der Waals force.
And when they are
getting closer together,
the pressure in
between the liquid,
the electric double
layer increases.
And that's a repulsive.
So this is the potential
from the force to potential.
And you superimposed the two.
You say, which one wins?
And if the Van der Waals
force is very strong,
it will be just
attracted to each other.
And so what do you want?
So if I do the superposition
of the two forces,
you could have
different scenarios.
And one scenario is like this.
And here is the
Van der Waals force
and then the repulsive potential
due to the electrostatic.
When they get really close, this
Van der Waals force wins again,
so they start to
attract each other.
And now, if you look
at the situation,
the particle tends to stay
to a minimum energy point.
And there are
different scenarios.
One minimum is here, and the
absolute minimum is here.
And this minimum-- if the
potential barrier here
is much larger than the
KT, then you actually
have a quasi-stable.
Colloids is a quasi-stable.
You can stay this way, keep a
distance between the particles
until somehow you
force them much closer.
So this is a different
scenario you can have that
will push the particle away.
[? And/or ?] you
could have this,
the Van der Waals
[? force ?] wins.
And in this case, you'll
never get stability.
I wasn't sure
whether, in this case,
you can get stability,
because this [INAUDIBLE]
consider only two particles.
Maybe [? they ?] all pushed the
boundaries of the container.
And so this one is the
real, say, [INAUDIBLE]
[? metastable ?] state.
And that's when [? you ?] want
to use the electrostatic method
to stabilize the colloids.
And in that case, you know if
you want to destabilize it,
you add a drop of salt, it
will just fall to the bottom.
You changed your
electrostatic potential.
And there are different ways.
There are other ways.
So this is when you deal
with an ionic solution.
It's much easier.
And when you deal with a
non-polar solution where you
cannot [? adjust ?] to the ions
concentration in the solution,
it's much more difficult. And in
that case, what you do is you,
for example, wrap the surface
of the particle with polymers.
And you use the
[? configurational ?]
repulsion.
And say people call
[? different-- ?]
there are different
forces in this case
to stabilize the solution.
So this is a surfactant
way to stabilize.
And, in fact, I was thinking
even this morning whether
the surfactant-- how to--
I haven't checked.
I have to say, I haven't
checked the literature.
People use [? entropic ?]
energy, all that to explain.
I was just thinking
whether one could still
go to modify the
Lifshitz theory,
and somehow whether this
polymer can introduce repulsion,
just like we say you can
have a repulsive force
if the dielectric constant
of the mediums are different.
But I wasn't sure.
I acknowledge I didn't
check the literature.
So that's the basics with
the electric double layer.
And if you do microfluidics
or nanofluidics,
you know that people have
used the electric double layer
when you deal with the liquid.
This is where there
are a lot of technology
advances in the past.
And people using the electric
double layer to make devices.
And one of the
well-established is--
this is long before
micro-nanotechnology--
that's the electroosmosis
or electrophoretics.
First, electrophoretic.
And the phoretic is always
some particle is moving,
solids are moving.
And when we have
electrophoretic, what
that means is I have particles.
I put them in liquid,
say, ionic liquid.
And the particle will, of
course, have absorbed the ions.
And then, say, the
surrounding has a counterions.
And effectively, when I
apply electrical field
on the particle, they will
[? move depend on the ?]
[? lead ?] imbalance.
So [? a ?] factor with this
particle is [? like a ?]
charged particle.
When I give electrical field,
the particle is removed.
And of course, the
motion is the balance
of the driving force, which is
the electrical static force,
the charge times electrical
field balance of the drag
force, which is a typical
small particle you can use
this [INAUDIBLE] expression.
So if I do this, I apply
an electrical field--
and in fact, you
can say depends on
whether it's a positive
or negative charge,
you can go different directions.
[? Surface ?] charge.
So if it's that, you can
tell whether the surface
of the solid is charged
positively or negatively.
And even though say their
surrounding [? charge is ?]
[? moving ?]
[? within ?] liquid.
But there's a lead
charge difference.
I do the balance is 3
pi mu d times velocity--
that's the Stokes' force.
And then I have the
charge on the surface, Q,
times the electric field.
And this gives me the velocity.
I can use Q times
electric field,
apply, [? and ?] 3 pi mu d.
You use this to,
for example, you
can measure the velocity
of the particle moving.
You can use that to do your
particle [? sizing. ?] Or,
you can also use that--
most of the time,
people actually
use this to determine
the Q on the surface.
And the Q, this one is
not the surface potential
because it's a flat surface.
If the particle is
negatively charged,
there are surrounding
also positive charges
that adhere to the surface.
And there are some [? shear, ?]
there are some mobile charges
still moving with it.
So effectively, you are really
looking at the [INAUDIBLE]
charge in a certain
sphere that [? affects ?]
the movement with the solid.
And this potential,
you can go to say
what's the effective potential?
That your zeta potential.
Zeta potential is this
Q and 2 pi, epsilon 0,
epsilon r and approximately
is the thickness
of the [? bilayer. ?]
And the D is diameter over 2.
So when this is a much
larger than the diameter,
you can see that the
[? measure ?] of zeta potential
is effective [? even ?]
[? though ?] it's measuring
the number of charge.
So this is the
electrophoretic flow,
where you use the field to
[? derive ?] the particle
motion.
And people will have--
you can actually
buy commercial equipment
that's the, for example,
the measure, the zeta
potential pretty much based
on this principle.
And the other situation
is let's suppose
you want to use the electric
field to [? derive ?]
a fluid flow in the channel.
And if you have solid,
you have a liquid inside,
and you have, in
this case, if you
apply a voltage, electric field
in the flow in the [? actual ?]
direction, and now what happens
is, of course, you have fixed
the ions that do not move.
You have the double
layer ions that's mobile.
And this double
layer, of course,
is only near the surface.
So if we apply our
electric field,
this double layer
will move supposedly
in this other positively
charged double layer.
And they will move towards
the [? field ?] direction.
And because they
are moving, they
will drag the surrounding
fluids to move.
So what you have is essentially
actually because now
it's almost like have a
slip boundary condition.
You do have a very thin layer
between this [INAUDIBLE]
[? layer ?] and the
[? submerged ?] immobile ions.
That's very thin-- a few
nanometers, for example.
And the rest is all moving.
So it's like a
[? plug ?] flow where
the velocity distribution
through the whole channel
is a uniform.
So you draw it.
It's pretty much a
plug flow situation,
except really close
to the surface.
And so of course, then you have
to balance your [? whiskers. ?]
And this is how people use, for
example, electoralosmotic pump.
This is [? electoralosmotic. ?]
And you can show that
the velocity here of this
motion is epsilon 0, epsilon R,
and they apply electrical
field [? and ?] viscosity.
And they are, again,
the zeta potential.
So that's the electrokinetics,
including phoretic, osmotic,
and that due to the
electrical double layer.
And what we move in on last is
talking about surface tension
and phase change.
Surface tension.
So what is surface tension?
First question is, what's
a unit of surface tension?
Newton per meter.
So let's look at,
understand a little bit more
on surface tension.
Surface tension is the energy.
So first, the unit
is newton per meter.
You think of it
typically as a force,
surface tension as a force.
But then, I can write
this newton times
meter per meter squared.
That's [? joule ?]
per meter squared.
What is it?
It's a surface energy.
So the surface tension
is how much energy
I need to create a surface.
And we can start with
the same material.
So if I have material
one I want to break it.
What's the minimum energy I
need to break the surface?
The minimum energy
I [? need ?] is
once I break into two halves, I
got two exposed surfaces there.
So the surface energy is then
the surface energy [? comma ?]
one is then half of
the minimal work I
need to do to create this
two [INAUDIBLE] surfaces.
So that's the cohesive energy.
It's the same material.
How much energy do you need?
It's a cohesive energy.
Cohesion.
And W here is the
work of cohesion.
And so this is one case.
Now, if I have two different
material, 1 and then 2,
how much energy do I
need to break and create
two different surfaces?
Material 1 and material 2.
And this is the
interface between two
different materials.
That's my surface tension
between the two materials.
So from an energy perspective,
it's much easier to understand.
And my surface tension--
so surface tension
exists for any surface--
not only liquid, but also solid.
And the surface tension
in this case, r 1 2,
can be expressed in terms
of the surface energy,
r1, plus r2 minus 2 times r.
So here, I only look at
the Van der Waals part.
So Van der Waals
part of this break--
how much Van der
Waals surface energy
if I break up surface 1 only,
and I break up surface 2 only?
So this gives us some ways to
estimate the surface energy,
surface tension.
Now, you go back to what
we dealt with before.
I can think about really
when I [? bring ?]
two surface together--
what's the-- here, we discuss
what's the Van der Waals force?
What's the Van der
Waals potential
between the two surfaces?
So it's this basics.
You can actually do your
back-of-envelope calculation
in terms of how strong is the
boundary between two surfaces,
and of course, say too for this
part, there is a covalent part.
If the two surfaces
are covalently bounded,
I just can't deal with easily.
I told you how to
calculate Van der
Waals, the dipole-dipole
interaction
and charge-dipole
interaction, but I can't
do easily the covalent bonds.
That requires more
sophisticated calculation
based on, for example, quantum
mechanics, Schrodinger equation
solution.
So with this basic
understanding, you can--
of course, you all heard
about Laplace's equation.
And so we have
Laplace's equation.
If I have a sphere-- the
simplest case is a sphere--
and then I have the
difference in the local radius
of curvature, I have the
pressure difference, which you
can say is p inside, outside.
And there is a two gamma over r.
r is the radius of the sphere.
So gamma is the surface
tension, surface energy.
That's the Laplace equation.
The Young equation
is when you have
a droplet on the different
surface, where you have--
whether the droplet
was spread or not,
so the contact angle of this
is really energy balance,
or you can think of this-- it's
much it's easier in this case--
it will force balance.
I have medium 3,
medium 1, and medium 2,
the contact angle, theta.
So you do your force balance.
You will say this is gamma 2, 3.
And here, gamma 1
3 and gamma 1 2.
So I have gamma 1 3 equals
gamma 2 3 cosine theta
plus gamma 1 2.
And this is the Young equation.
Sometimes, we call this
Laplace-Young equation.
So you know this, I'm
sure, and you have
seen in different situations.
And what I'm going
to discuss next
is the size effect
on phase transition.
And with this
basic understanding
on the surface tension, let's
look at the size effects
on phase transition.
So if I have a droplet
or a vapor bubble,
it turns out that the
thermodynamic properties
of this droplet or bubble are
very different from [? both ?]
materials.
And this is based on if I have--
[? or ?] this also
apply when I have, say,
a [? solid ?] nanoparticle
[? in ?] the melting.
This could all happen.
So basically, I'm looking at
the equilibrium thermodynamics
of a particle with
the surrounding.
And this particle could be
a liquid droplet or a vapor.
And when I look at
the equilibrium,
I'm looking at the
max equilibrium.
What's the condition
for max equilibrium.
What's the condition?
Mass transfer.
You all forget?
So the chemical potential
[? grid. ?] The [? chemical ?]
potential on both
sides of the equation.
The equilibrium, you have
mechanical is the pressure,
heat is a temperature,
[? mass ?] is a [? chemical ?]
potential.
You can't forget that.
So what I have is the
chemical potential [INAUDIBLE]
That's always my condition.
And the chemical
potential turns out
in the differential
form for each phase.
This is where you can see
the Gibbs free energy is
the [INAUDIBLE] minus TS.
And for each phase,
the Gibbs free energy
is mu times n times mu, number
of particle times the chemical
potential.
And with these two together, you
can prove the Gibbs [INAUDIBLE]
equation, which says where
I have SDT [? minus ?]
[? weight, ?] the specific
volume DP, plus d mu equals 0.
That's the starting
point to derive
all the [INAUDIBLE] expressions
is Gibbs [INAUDIBLE] relation
plus the pressure.
Because we have two phases--
this applies to each phase--
when two phases
are in equilibrium,
[? d mu ?] difference
between the two are 0,
because the [? mu ?] [? prime ?]
[? mu ?] equals mu double
prime.
So let's look at the
case where, of course,
I have the pressure difference,
dp prime minus [? p ?] double
prime minus [? TP ?] prime
equals 2D 2 gamma or r.
That's the Laplace equation.
And now, I first consider
the phase change,
which happens also under
constant temperature.
Temperature doesn't change
between in the phase change
process.
And the equilibrium, the
two chemical potential
must be the same.
So what I have here--
this doesn't change,
this doesn't change.
And what I need to have
is then the two phases,
v dp v prime dp prime equals v
double prime DP double prime.
Specific volume times
the pressure that's
equal to each other to balance
to have the equilibrium
condition so that the chemical
potential on both sides.
And with the two,
I can replace, say,
the pressure-- say one of these.
I can replace, for
example, specific volume.
But I need to say which one
is vapor phase because I
don't know.
In the vapor phase, I
use an ideal gas law.
So if I have first
[? as ?] a droplet,
I keep my p double prime.
And so let me say
first I have a droplet.
If it's a droplet, and it's
say-- so in the vapor phase,
I have v prime equals
rt and p prime.
So that's in the vapor
phase here, v prime equals.
So I can replace with p prime.
And then, I can put a p double
prime in terms of p prime.
So I can eliminate or have an
equation to solve for dp prime
only.
And if you solve
for that, so combine
with the equation
we have, you'll
find out the p prime
equals p zero exponential.
And 2 gamma over r
[? and ?] v double prime rt.
v double prime is the liquid.
The specific volume of the
liquid doesn't change much.
So I can keep that as a constant
when I do the integration.
And this shows that if
I have liquid droplets,
and a small droplet, the
corresponding outside vapor
pressure is higher.
So what does that mean?
If I have a cloud of droplets
of different size at the one
temperature, what happens
to the small droplet?
AUDIENCE: It [? grows ?] faster.
PROFESSOR: The small
droplet will evaporate
faster because the vapor
pressure is higher,
so they will disappear.
So it's the bigger
particle wins.
And if you do
solid, for example,
that's called the
Ostwald ripening,
your nanoparticle together.
Bigger nanoparticle will
eat the small nanoparticles.
And if you do liquid, let's
just say they are small.
Small droplets disappear faster.
And now, if I do a
bubble, you do the same.
You reverse it.
In this case, your
bubble is inside.
So p double prime
is say [? NRT. ?]
And then you solve
your equation again.
What I have is p double
prime equals p 0 exponential
minus 2 gamma r v prime.
Outside is a liquid, so
v prime is constant RT.
So pressure will be lower.
The vapor pressure of
the bubble is lower.
What does that mean?
For example, this
is where people
want to use a
capillary condensation.
You have nanochannels
or micronchannels.
The liquid will condense
into the channel.
And in the condensation,
let's suppose
this is a vapor, v prime.
And let's say liquid is here.
[? Now, ?] it's a
[? half ?] bubble.
It's the same scenario.
And in this case--
Oh, I'm sorry.
This is a double prime,
this is a v prime.
My inside is double prime.
This is the inside.
The curvature here
is double prime.
So what it says in
this curvature region,
the vapor pressure
is lower than bulk.
And what it means is that
if I have a vapor here
at a certain temperature, I can
still have condensation inside
at that temperature.
And that's a capillary
condensation.
And this will happen until
you [? feel ?] to the top.
And eventually, at the top, your
[? coverage ?] will disappear.
You don't have
condensation anymore.
And you can do
further same analysis.
So here, we're doing the
vapor pressure analysis.
You can even do the
temperature analysis.
So if I have a
nanoparticle, and here, I
can write during the
phase change process,
delta S is delta h over
T. That's the phase change
temperature.
So you can again go back to
the phase change process,
analyze what will be the
trend for my temperature
change of particles?
And you will find out if
I have a small particle,
the delta ht 0 minus t equals
[? here ?] is r [? log ?] 2
gamma r plus P
prime over P prime.
So what this tells me--
if I have a small droplet,
the melting temperature compared
to a flat surface melting
temperature will be lower.
And this has been
even proven in solid,
where they are
[? experimenting. ?] If you
make a silver nanoparticles
and you put [? there ?]
the temperature could be as
low as the melting temperature
of, [? say, ?] just
100 or 200 degree.
So people try to use this effect
to print the nanoparticles
and make printable circuit,
and you can put it [? in ?]
plastic, and you fire up
to a very low temperature,
they will solidify
the [? group. ?]
And, in fact, I say once I was
thinking about this identifier
patent, but then
somebody else did it.
And people think about
using the interface.
And if you think about solder,
solder is a lower temperature,
but it's typically
made of alloys,
and alloy has a little bit
worse thermal conductivity.
But if I just use
silver nanoparticles
with a low temperature, I can
still fire the 100, 200 degree.
And they will [? grow ?] big.
But it's permanent.
Once they grow big,
they have higher thermal
[? conductivity. ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? random. ?] [? I ?] used
to have entropy
generation table.
That's one of the
[? ideas ?] generated,
[? identifier ?] patents.
Somebody did it.
[INAUDIBLE]
So you can explore those
kind of different effects.
And these are all classical.
All those relationships
were derived by Kelvin.
Kelvin wrote over 500 papers.
Poisson only wrote 27 papers.
[INAUDIBLE] So you don't
have to write many papers
to leave your name behind, OK?
There are [? people who ?]
write a lot.
Every paper is important.
And the final comment
is even surface tension
can depend on the size.
So they are also [? theories ?]
on the surface tension
[? sides ?] dependent
on surface tension.
These were discussed
in the book.
And with that, I close
this discussion on liquid
and the last lecture of
what I'm going to do.
I'm surprised I can
actually go to chapter 10.
Many times, I stopped chapter
7, so you have been enduring
me very moving very fast.
But I'll talk about more on
the linear response theory
molecular dynamics
[? simulation. ?]